♪ ♪ ♪
- "Maria Chapdelaine", c'est
un classique des classique.
Bien qu'il soit considéré comme
un chef-d'oeuvre de littérature
canadienne française, c'est
Louis Emond, un Français,
qu'il l'a écrit.
SÉBASTIEN RICARD, interprète
de Samuel Chapdelaine
- Moi, je trouve que ça parle
beaucoup de l'identité
québécoise, t'sais, ce mot
qui est revenu à l'avant-plan,
puis c'est pour dire à quel
point l'identité, c'est
quelque chose d'insaisissable.
HÉLÈNE FLORENT,
interprète de Laura Chapdelaine
- J'aime ça dire aussi que
c'est une histoire d'amour,
amour du lieu, amour du terrain,
amour de la région,
de poser sa maison.
- Le livre remporte un immense
succès en France dès sa parution
en 1913. Et c'est la quatrième
fois que Maria Chapdelaine
est adaptée au cinéma.
SÉBASTIEN PILOTE, réalisateur,
"Maria Chapdelaine"
- Cette histoire-là, qui est
pourtant très, très simple,
une grande profondeur,
une grande richesse qui fait
que... que je pense que c'est
possible de dire de nouvelles
choses avec... cette vieille
histoire, dans le fond.
- Plus de 1000 jeunes filles ont
auditionné pour le rôle, mais
en rencontrant Sara Monpetit,
le réalisateur, Sébastien
Pilote, savait qu'il venait
de trouver sa Maria.
SARA MONTPETIT, interprète
de Maria Chapdelaine
- Oui, c'est une histoire
de 1910, mais dans le fond
des choses, Maria peut autant
être ma mère, ma soeur
et les femmes d'avant
et même mon grand-père.
Mon grand-père a eu le choix,
ma mère est Argentine et
il a eu le choix de soit
rester en Argentine ou de
venir à Montréal. Il a décidé
de rester en Argentine et
juste ça me fait penser à Maria.
- Devant Maria, trois soupirants
bien différents s'affrontent
pour gagner son coeur.
Le citadin Lorenzo Surprenant.
- Je suis revenu
pour vous, Maria.
ROBERT NAYLOR, interprète
de Lorenzo Surprenant
- Mon personnage représente
la modernité, le passage au...
à la prochaine époque, en fait.
Puis, c'est lui qui demande
à Maria de... d'oublier ses...
ses racines, en fait, puis
de partir un peu à l'aventure.
- Alors, vous allez partir?
- Le voisin, Eutrope Gagnon.
ANTOINE OLIVIER PILON,
interprète d'Eutrope Gagnon
- Je le vois comme la tradition,
en fait, Eutrope, cette espèce
de sécurité-là qui...
Ce qu'il a à offrir,
lui, c'est ce dans quoi
Maria été élevée, en fait.
- Tu as déjà entendu
quelque chose contre moi?
- Et le rebelle et téméraire
François Paradis.
ÉMILE SCHNEIDER,
interprète de François Paradis
- Mais c'est beaucoup de
promesses, fait qu'on y croit,
mais on sait pas. Ce qui est
sûr, c'est que leurs coeurs
sont en feu, ils sont amoureux.
- "Maria Chapdelaine",
c'est bien plus qu'une simple
histoire d'amour.
- Ça raconte autant
une histoire... de famille,
de passation, de destin, de
choix. Je pense que l'histoire
d'amour, c'est une fioriture
qu'on rajoute, qu'on a envie :
"Ah! Ils vont-tu se frencher,
ils vont-tu se tenir la main?"
Mais dans le fond, c'est
beaucoup plus profond que ça.
(chant)
- "Maria Chapdelaine", c'est
un pan de notre histoire qui
continue d'inspirer et qui est
magnifiquement porté à l'écran
dans cette nouvelle incarnation.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.